callan gets his vasectomy reversed i'll
get mine reversed you got a vasectomy no
i didn't i have a baby
he just had a dude he has a one month
old baby
yeah any more questions matt he's 55.
yeah matt dude he's hugh hefner you
[ __ ] come on
let's go matt yeah matt what's up dude i
can do it you can do that you got this
dime piece over with these crazy jeans
it's not it's not a joke no yeah we were
all surprised i mean it's a joke but
it's not a joke
we joke about it a lot of [ __ ] hype
and you have a child as a hierarchy
yeah i had to tell for a couple of years
some things happened when the kid's
twenties he's gonna be 80
80 years they're like oh your grandpa's
at the game
listen you just i'm so [ __ ] impressed
with you right now thank you yeah
how did you never sew it up what was
that i um i was told to and uh i just
didn't you just kept splurting yeah
sometimes it feels too good sometimes
you just like i grappled two days after
you got a vasectomy and my balls hurt so
bad oh god why did we do it do that
because i was like i'll be all right but
it won't be why would you show obviously
a vasectomy
yeah you can reverse because i have
three [ __ ] kids he's got three kids
and he likes splurt you know what i'm
saying but does it shoot like dust i got
that hosie dude he he
got it snipped because he likes splurge
oh man yeah i don't pull up
there's two things i don't [ __ ] with
it's rattlesnakes and condoms and i'm
just trying to have a good time baby